so und damit kommen wir zum nächsten
Tagesordnungspunkt da geht es um den
Bundeswehreinsatz in Bosnien-Herzegowina
die Bundeswehr war bis 2012 schon an der
Operation European Union Force Altea in
Bosnien-Herzegowina beteiligt hat dann
aber ihre Soldaten zurückgezogen und nun
sollen aber Soldatinnen und Soldaten
wieder in den balkanten Start um
besonders dort Wahlen abzusichern freie
und unabhängige Wahlen soweit es geht am
2 oktober sollen diese stattfinden denn
man hat Angst dass angesichts von doch
mehr Einfluss von Nationalisten von doch
lauter werdenden nationalistischen Tönen
diese die Wahl beeinflussen könnten und
auch das von Russland eventuell eine
Einflussnahme da stattfinden könnte und
deswegen sollen maximal 50 Soldaten und
Soldaten in das Land geschickt werden
können Philipp Krämer spricht als erstes
Herr Präsidentin sehr geehrte
Kolleginnen und Kollegen der Westbalkan
und die benachbarten Staaten sind nach
wie vor von ethnischen Spannungen
betroffen nicht erst seit dem russischen
Angriff auf die Ukraine treten die
Konfliktlinien und diametralen
geopolitischen Interessen zu Tage seit
dem 24 Februar nun aber im Besonderen
Nationalismen erleben aktuell trotz
aller eu-beitrittsperspektiven Abkommen
und westanährung erneut Konjunktur die
jüngst die Ausschreitung
nordmazedonischer Nationalisten in
Skopje deutlich gemacht haben
zwar das Zusammenspiel aus
Friedensabkommen Friedenstruppen
politischem Aufbau und einer
europäischen Zukunftsperspektive das
Land seit dem daytherner Abkommen
relativ befriedet schwache staatliche
Strukturen gefährden jedoch weiter in
die Stabilität des multi-ethnischen
Staates die separatistischen Bemühungen
der Republik sripska gestützt von
Serbien und seiner traditionellen
Schutzmacht Russland legen schon seit
längerem die Lunte an diese explosive
Gemengelage
der letztjährige Rückzug der Republik
sriwska aus der gemeinsamen Armee dem
Justizsystem und Steuerwesen
Provokationen durch verfassungswidrige
paramilitärische verraten
Geschichtsrevisionismus und anderes
destabilisierendes Verhalten lassen uns
besorgt zurück und ermahnen uns zu
Wachsamkeit der reibungslose Ablauf der
Parlaments und Präsidentschaftswahlen im
Oktober muss unter allen Umständen
gewährleistet sein von der Legitimität
dieser Wahlen als freie unabhängige und
gleiche demokratische Willensbekundung
hängt die Zukunft und die territoriale
Einheit Bosnien-Herzegowinas ab das
zündeln dodex in den vergangenen Monaten
die weiteren Sezessionsbestrebungen der
serbischen Teilrepublik sind Vorzeichen
eines weiteren Krieges in Europa ein
solcher Krieg wäre eine große tragierte
Tragödie für alle Beteiligten
es gibt in dem nichts zu gewinnen außer
menschliches Leid auf allen Seiten und
dies kann und wird das vereinte Europa
der Demokratien der souveränen
Staatlichkeit und der Menschenrechte
nicht zulassen der einzige Nutzen eines
solchen Krieges wäre eine weitere dich
Stabilisierung des Westbalkans und
Europas das muss Gotik und seinen
Kumpanen klar sein mit einer Eskalation
machen sie sich vollends zu Putins
Marionetten
[Applaus]
für uns westeuropäische Staaten hat
dieses bedrohliche Szenario jedoch
weitere Implikationen nicht nur russland
hatte seine Hände im Spiel China
schließt diese Region systematisch an
seine Belt und Road Initiative an und
hat zuletzt Serbien mit der
exportvariante seines modernsten
flugabwehrsystems beliefert hier kann
durchaus von einer einseitigen
Aufrüstung gesprochen werden aber all
jene die hier mit Europas Zukunft
spielen sollten sich einer Sache bewusst
sein und sich hier auch keinen falschen
Illusionen hingeben wir sehen das wir
verstehen die Implikation und dennoch
stehen wir zu unserer Verantwortung als
Teil der europäischen Familie
wir werden keinen weiteren Angriffskrieg
oder ethno-nationalistischen Völkermord
in Europa zulassen eine erneute
Mandatierung von Altea ist ein
Anfangsbeitrag dazu einem solchen
Szenario bereits jetzt präventiv zu
begegnen daher werden wir heute für
dieses Mandat meine Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
als grüne Fraktion haben wir euch vor
Altea stets unterstützt und sind der
Meinung dass dieser Stabilität bringende
Einsatz fortgeführt und durch deutsche
Beteiligung gestärkt werden muss über
die Präsident über die
präsenzmandatierter Truppen und
Mediation im Land hinaus schafft Altea
Grundlagen für eine friedliche Zukunft
in Bosnien und Herzegowina die
Soldatinnen und Soldaten bilden
minenräume Teams aus und es wird eine
Eingreifreserve vorgehalten dem Notfall
schnell mobilisiert werden kann um
etwaige Eskalation einzudämmen ich
bedanke mich schon jetzt für den Einsatz
der Beteiligten Soldatinnen und Soldaten
der Bundeswehr die schnell und flexibel
und trotz aller weiteren Belastungen
über den Sommer verlegt werden und dort
dann in einem zeitlich sehr engen
Korridor ihre Aufgaben übernehmen werden
können
neben dem erneuten Einsatz der
Bundeswehr im Rahmen des Alters müssen
wir uns aber auch intensiv damit
beschäftigen wie die Region weiter
politisch stabilisiert werden kann
Russland könnte im November die
Verlängerung des eufermandats im
UN-Sicherheitsrat blockieren für diesen
Fall müssen wir vorbereitet sein eine
Möglichkeit durch die man Russland im
Sicherheitsrat umgehen könnte liegt auf
der Hand die EU sollte eine Einleitung
seitens Bosnien und Herzegowina erwirken
die äuvermission vorzusetzen dies sollte
vor dem Hintergrund der jüngst
geschlossenen Vereinbarung möglich sein
meine Damen und Herren ist werbe für die
Unterstützung dieses Mandates was auch
im geostrategischen Kontext ein weiterer
Baustein ist gerade auch vor dem
Hintergrund des Krieges in der Ukraine
herzlichen Dank
Philipp Krämer hat hier die erste Rede
gehalten in dieser Debatte zum
Bundeswehr Einsatz und auf ihn voll Knut
Abraham CDU CSU-Fraktion und
ausgebildete Diplomat frau Präsidentin
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen der
Balkan schaut sehr genau nach Berlin von
hier aus sind zu unserer Regierungszeit
die richtigen und die wichtigen
Initiativen für den Südosten Europas
ausgegangen damit meine ich vor allem
den im Kontext der EU-Erweiterung
angesiedelten Berliner Prozess ein
wichtiges Scharnier zwischen
interregionaler Zusammenarbeit und
großen europäischen
konnektivitätsprojekten vorangetrieben
von Bundeskanzlerin Angela Merkel gut
dass Sie meine Damen und Herren von der
derzeitigen Bundesregierung auf diesem
Weg fortfahren
heute schauen wir von hier aus auf den
Balkan mit der Wiederaufnahme der
deutschen Beteiligung an der
sicherheitsoperation EU vor alltera tut
die momentane Bundesregierung das
Richtige und dafür findet sie unsere
Unterstützung der Personaleinsatz von
bis zu 50 Personen dürfte zwar eine
militärisch eher begrenzte Wirkung haben
insofern hatte der Kollege Armin Schwarz
neulich in der vorangegangenen Lesung
recht als er von weder Fisch noch
Fleisch sprach aber die symbolische
Bereitschaft Deutschlands auch zum
militärischen Engagement ist von großer
Wichtigkeit
wenn wir heute über Altea und Bosnien
Herzegowina sprechen geht es um drei
zentrale Dinge mit der Wiederaufnahme
der deutschen Beteiligung senden wir das
Signal dass wir fest zur
Nachkriegsordnung in Bosnien-Herzegowina
stehen dass wir uns in der Verantwortung
für diesen Staat und seine Demokratie
sehen wie unvollkommen und
reformbedürftig sie auch sein mag seit
1995 gab es acht freie und demokratische
Wahlen auf Staatsebene die sowohl in der
Föderation wie auch in der Republica
sofska zu machtwechseln geführt hatten
es ist wichtig diesen Erfolg der
bosnischen Demokratie zu bewahren daher
unterstützen wir auch den Hohen
Repräsentanten der internationalen
Gemeinschaft Christian Schmidt mit aller
Kraft
bei einer anstehenden Reform der
datenvereinbarung wird es aus meiner
Sicht darum gehen wie die drei
konstitutiven Völker des Landes ihre
Gleichberechtigung Regeln und
Minderheitenrechte für die kleineren
Volksgruppen garantieren und wie die
demokratische Zivilgesellschaft
eingebunden wird
zum zweiten und das war ja eben auch
schon zu hören senden wir mit unserer
Bereitschaft zur Wiederaufnahme der
Beteiligung ein klares und deutliches
Signal nach Moskau wir wissen was
zwischen dem bosnischen Serbenführer
Dodik und dem Kreml gespielt wird aber
wir lassen uns weder provozieren noch
einschüchtern mit unserer militärischen
Präsenz machen wir es der russischen
destabilisierungspolitik die auch auf
dem Balkan umgesetzt wird schwerer
und zum dritten geht es um die Zukunft
was den herzegowina's in Europa die
Vision für diesen Vielvölkerstaat ist
klar das Land braucht die Perspektive
einer EU-Mitgliedschaft sonst werden
Nationalismus und Destabilisierung ob
Siegen mit all den negativen
Konsequenzen die wir in der Geschichte
zu oft in der Region und auch aus der
Region erlebt haben
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen Bosnien
wird nur mit einem europäischen Dach
funktionieren und je schneller dieses
Dach gebaut werden kann desto besser
natürlich braucht es
natürlich braucht es für den Bau des
Daches die richtigen Rahmenbedingungen
und Voraussetzung womit wir wieder bei
Althea und unserem Wiedereinstieg wählen
denn ohne sicherheitspolitische
Stabilität wird es auch mit dem
EU-Beitrittsprozess nicht vorangehen und
dieser braucht jetzt einen Booster er
muss beschleunigt werden das Land
braucht Kandidatenstatus der Glaube der
Menschen an die Erreichbarkeit der
Mitgliedschaft der in der EU muss
wiederbelebt werden es geht um die
Glaubwürdigkeit der europäischen Zukunft
dieses Landes
die Wiederaufnahme der deutschen
Beteiligungen an altera ist das richtige
Zeichen zur richtigen Zeit die
cdu/csu-bundestagsfraktion unterstützt
daher den Antrag der Bundesregierung der
begleitende Antrag der momentan
Bundesregierung tragenden Fraktion ist
konsequent wenn auch irgendwie ein
bisschen lieblos und peblos also
irgendwie ohne neue Ideen aber da steht
einer Zustimmung durch uns natürlich
nicht im Wege das Signal ist richtig wir
stehen zu Bosnien-Herzegowina auch mit
unserem militärischen Beitrag vielen
Dank für Ihre Aufmerksamkeit
hat jetzt das Wort für die SPD-Fraktion
sitzt im Auswärtigen Ausschuss
gleich
vorweglose Zustimmung würden wir uns
sehr sehr freuen gleich sehr gut sehr
geehrte Frau Präsidentin
meine Damen und Herren von allem was der
Mensch baut und aufbaut gibt es nichts
besseres und wertvolleres als Brücken
diese Aussage stammt vom
Literaturnobelpreisträger Ivo Andric
geboren in Bosnien-Herzegowina
katholisch getauft und verstorben in
Belgrad
multinationaler kann man gar nicht sein
Brücken bauen darum geht es letztendlich
immer im Leben zwischen Menschen
Kulturen Religionen Nachbarstaaten oder
ganzen Regionen und Kontinenten als
Mitglieder des Deutschen Bundestages
versuchen wir alle politische
Architekten und Architekten zu sein
dabei ist das Fundament auf dem wir
arbeiten unsere freiheitlich
demokratische Grundordnung und die Tiefe
europäische Überzeugung
Bosnien-Herzegowina und seine Menschen
wünschen sich ebenfalls solch einen
Konstrukt mit identischen Grundpfeilern
Frieden und Freiheit Demokratie und
Wohlstand und deshalb liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen ist die heutige Debatte und
das beschließen der beiden Anträge ein
historischer Wendepunkt ins Gute für die
Zukunft dieser jungen Demokratie deshalb
gilt mein Dank an die
koalitionsfraktion und meine
berichterstatterkollegen Boris miatovic
von den Grünen Thomas Saka von der FDP
sowie der Zeiten sie sich fest der
Abraham an die cdu/csu-fraktion die
bereit ist alle gemeinsam mit uns diese
Verantwortung zu tragen und ein klares
Signal zu entsenden vielen vielen Dank
für dieses klare Signal heute hier
die Inhalte der beiden Anträge haben in
den letzten Wochen und Monaten für viel
Diskussionsstoff gesorgt und das ist
auch gut so
zum Teil bis in überzogenen rassistisch
und nationalistisch wurden einige
Mitglieder von uns aus dem Deutschen
Bundestag attackiert aber was zeigt uns
das das zeigt dass wir eine Nerv
getroffen haben möglicherweise sehr sehr
tief den Finger in die Wunde gelegt
unser Plan für eine bessere Zukunft für
bosnetzegowina sieht 22 Punkte vor 22
Punkte die untergliedert werden können
in drei Dimensionen eins von drei eine
sicherheitspolitische Dimension wir
wollen nach zehn Jahren Abwesenheit
erneut an euphoaltermandat beteiligen
wir stellen uns klar gegen
sezessionsversuche und lehnen die
Gründung einer dritten Entität ab
sanktionen müssen die erhalten die an
der Zerstörung staatlicher Strukturen
Arbeiten Demokratie und Wohlstand
brauchen ein starkes und stabiles Gerüst
gegen jede Form von etonationalismus wir
werden die territoriale Integrität und
Souveränität von Bosnien-Herzegowina
verteidigen
[Applaus]
zwei von drei eine europäische Dimension
Bosnien-Herzegowina gehört zur
europäischen Familie es muss zeitnah den
EU-Kandidatenstatus erhalten auch
deshalb werden wir die in träge Wahlen
werden die integere Wahlen im Oktober 22
unterstützen wir stehen an der Seite des
Hohen Repräsentanten Christian Schmidt
CSU Mitglied
und werden die proeuropäischen Parteien
voll und ganz unterstützen auf ihrem Weg
zu einem demokratischen Staat das
Konzept der konstruktiven Völker ist
gescheitert es benötigt ein modernes
demokratisches und europäisches Prinzip
auf allen Ebenen wo egal ist welcher
Religion man ist welcher ethnischen
Gruppe man zugehört wie man mit vor oder
Nachnamen heißt die einbürger eine
Stimme so wie wir es in Deutschland auch
kennen meine Damen und Herren
drei von drei die gesellschaftliche
Dimension es muss für alle Gleichheit
vor dem Gesetz herrschen das Land
benötigt eine starke Zivilgesellschaft
die Demokratisierung der staatlichen
gesellschaftlichen Strukturen politische
Bildung Kinder müssen die selben Chancen
halten einen diskriminierungsfreien
Bildungssystem und es braucht eine
unabhängige Medienlandschaft weil die
Zeit rennt liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen wir starten heute eine neue
Epoche für den Westbalkan für
Bosnien-Herzegowina national europäisch
und international denn die
Glaubwürdigkeit die EU wird auch einen
erzielten Fortschritten im Westbalkan
bemessen um zu Ende um zu enden wie ich
begonnen habe lassen sie uns anfangen
Brücken zu bauen die nicht einzustürzen
sind Demokratie Frieden Freiheit und
Wohlstand vielen Dank für Ihre
aufmerksam
soweit die
Rede von Adis ahmedowicz auf ihn folgt
Rüdiger Lucassen der Sprecher für
Verteidigung der afd-fraktion
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin sehr geehrte Kollegen
nach zehn Jahren schickt die
Bundesregierung deutsche Soldaten zurück
nach Bosnien warum weil man 27 Jahre
nach dem Abkommen von beten immer noch
berechtigte Sorge haben muss dass eine
Parlamentswahl die ganzen Balkan
anzündet 27 Jahre nach Dayton ist
Bosnien ein gescheiterter Staat die AFD
wird diesen Mandat nicht zustimmen wenn
der Bundestag die Bundeswehr ins Ausland
schickt dann müssen aus unserer Sicht
drei Voraussetzungen erfüllt sein
erstens es muss ein Mandat der
un-vorliegen nicht wie 1999 im Kosovo
zweitens es muss eindeutig eindeutig im
deutschen Interesse liegen nicht wie in
Mali und drittens es muss eine klare
Strategie für den Einsatz eben nicht wie
Mali im Irak im Kosovo Afghanistan und
eben auch jetzt nicht für Bosnien
Zurückhaltung
Zurückhaltung bei Auslandseinsätzen war
viele Jahrzehnte deutsche staatsresaison
aus vorgeschobenen historischen oder
echten
realpolitischen Gründen die älteren bei
SPD und Grünen erinnern sich bestimmt
noch und heute wird von links nichts
mehr hinterfragt eine Kollegin der
Grünen sagte im Ausschuss neulich dazu
dass Parlament solle keine Mucken machen
daran wird sich die AFD nicht halten
meine Damen und Herren
grundsätzlich liegt die Stabilität des
Balkans selbstverständlich in
Deutschlands Interesse ein instabiler
Balkan hat unmittelbarer Auswirkungen
auf Deutschland
Stichworte Flüchtlinge
Flüchtlinge Kriminalität und so weiter
aber mit dem erneuten Einsatz ja genau
das ist es aber mit dem erneuten Einsatz
der Bundeswehr in Bosnien ändert die
Bundesregierung nichts an dieser
Instabilität die gesamte
die gesamte EU-Mission ändert daran
nichts sie betreiben maximal
systembekämpfung ich verbessere
Symptombekämpfung das ist keine
Strategie und liegt nicht im deutschen
Interesse die ampelparteien führen diese
unsägliche Politik der
Auslandseinsätze nahtlos fort die
mandatstexte und Reden sind gefüllt mit
hohlen Absichtserklärungen und den
üblichen Schlagworten Demokratie
Partnerschaft Stabilität oder das
überstrapazierte Zeichen der Solidarität
es sind Dokumente der guten Gesinnung
auf Kosten eines tragfähigen Plans
irgendwie dabei sein
irgendwie dabei sein ist aber für die
AFD keine Politik im Gegenteil es ist
verantwortungslos gegenüber den Soldaten
gegenüber den Steuerzahlern gegenüber
dem deutschen Volk an dessen Stelle wir
hier heute entscheiden meine Damen
meine Damen und Herren es stimmt ja das
waren ein Problem wie das Staatsgebilde
Bosnien nicht isoliert betrachten darf
der ganze Balkan kann nicht isoliert
betrachtet werden die Konflikte und
Kriege die uns bedrohen hängen zusammen
nur mit der ständigen Analyse ist es
nicht getan eine Bundesregierung und
diese erst recht nicht ist auch keine
Denkfabrik sie muss handeln und einem
zusammenhängenden Problem auch eine
zusammenhängende Strategie
entgegensetzen die Absicherung einer
Wahl kann dann Teil dieser Strategie
sein so aber macht die Bundesregierung
einfach nur schlechte Politik und das
unterstützen wir nicht danke
Rüdiger Lukassen hat hier die Ablehnung
der afd-fraktion zu diesem
Bundeswehreinsatz begründet übrigens
wird auch die Linksfraktion hat schon
gesagt dass sie diesen Einsatz ablehnt
bevor eine Vertreterin der Linksfraktion
spricht ist aber erstmal die
FDP-Fraktion dran Thomas Hacker
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen jeder der schon
einmal im Sarajevo und
Bosnien-Herzegowina war kommt mit
intensiven mit überwältigenden
Eindrücken zurück neben den Rosen von
Sarajevo mit rotem Harz gefüllten Granat
Kratern die der Opfer des
Artilleriebeschusses gedenken ist eine
meiner einprägendsten Erinnerungen der
Besuch des
wortschalthotministeriums das Museum das
2017 gegründet wurde sammelt die vielen
Geschichten der Kinder die während des
Bosnienkrieges aufwuchsengeschichten von
Angst Verlust und Tod von Freunden
Geschwistern oder Eltern durch das
Bewahren der Erinnerung und mit ihr
verbundenen Erinnerungsstücken will das
Museum so einen Beitrag leisten die
entstandenen Traumata zu bewältigen
Traumata die 27 Jahre nach Ende des
Krieges immer noch omnipräsent sind
was uns der Autor Edo Popovic in seine
Literatur als Absurdität der
Postapokalypse miterleben lässt ist für
die Menschen vor Ort Lebensrealität das
ja doch eigentlich eine optimistische
Zukunft geformt werden müsste wie kann
das aber gelingen wenn die Menschen
immer wieder mit der Angst leben müssen
dass ihre Heimat wieder in einen dunklen
Abgrund stürzt eine allgegenwärtige
Angst immer weiter angefeuert von
serbischen kroatischen oder bosnischen
Nationalisten wie soll sich eine
Gesellschaft entwickeln wenn die
Integrität der eigenen Heimat immer
wieder in Frage gestellt wird und
ethnische Grenzen zum Spielball von
Machtinteressen von Machtpolitik werden
ethnische Grenzen die im Europa des 21
jahrhunderts doch längst überwunden sein
müssten
der Hohe Repräsentant und sei ehemaliger
Politik Christian Schmidt bezeichnet die
aktuelle Situation in Bozen und
Herzegowina als die dramatischste seit
dem Friedensabkommen von Daten 1995
Zeitenwende ist das geflügelte Wort des
Jahres 2022 weil wir uns mit einem
radikalen Paradigmenwechsel konfrontiert
sehen aber auch 95 war für Deutschland
schon eine Zeitenwende damals leidete
die Mandatierung der Beteiligung der
Bundeswehr bei der United Nations
protection Force und ifo einen
Paradigmenwechsel der deutschen
Außenpolitik ein Deutschland wurde
damals seiner besonderen Verantwortung
für den Frieden Europa und den Frieden
auf dem westlichen Balkan gerecht dieser
besonderen Verantwortung hat sich 30
Jahre nach dem Ausbruch des Krieges in
Bosnien nichts geändert das ist daher
richtig dass wir heute die Entsendung
von 50 Bundeswehrsoldaten in die Region
beschließen doch dieser wichtige Schritt
allein reicht nicht Verantwortung lässt
sich nicht in eine Mandat allein
abhandeln als Ampelkoalition wollen wir
auch die Ursachen der verschärften
Situation angehen dazu gehört dass wir
klare Antworten auf den
nationalistischen und separatistischen
Kräfte in BOS finden die das
Friedensabkommen von Dayton und ergraben
und aktiv verletzen das bedeutet dass
wir die EU wie es die USA und
Großbritannien bereits tun gezielte
Sanktionen gegen alliier diejenigen
verhängen die den Frieden im Land
gefährden und sabotieren unser Blick
muss ich dabei aber natürlich auch in
die Nachbarschaft von Bosnien und
Herzegowina richten Konflikte in einer
so multi-ethnischen Region sind niemals
isoliert zu betrachten wer wie der
serbische Präsident bucic proklamiert
sein Land in die EU führen zu wollen
muss wissen dass die aktive
Unterstützung von Separatisten wie
miloradodik mit einem Weg in die
Europäische Union nicht vereinbar ist
ein Schlüssel
ein Schlüssel zum Erfolg liegt wieder
einmal in der Geschlossenheit der
Europäischen Union in diesem Fall
gegenüber nationalistischen und
separatistischen Kräften in
Bosnien-Herzegowina das gilt bei der
Frage der Durchführung der Wahl im
Oktober als auch bei der Umsetzung der
Urteile des Europäischen Gerichtshof
hinsichtlich der viel diskutierten
Wahlrechtsreform eine Geschlossenheit
die wir uns von allen unseren
EU-Partnern einfordern insbesondere auch
von denen aus der Region
seitdem 24
februar ist der Krieg in Europa wieder
Realität wir müssen uns der
sicherheitspolitischen Dimension welche
die Stabilität des westlichen Balkans
für unseren gesamten Kontinent hat klar
Bewusstsein auch hier müssen wir den
Einfluss der Russischen Föderation
zurückdringen stärken wir die
Zivilgesellschaft des Landes indem ihr
Projekte zu Resilienz gegen Kreml der
Informationskampagnen und Fake News
ausbauen wenn der russische Botschafter
in einem Interview offen sagt dass ein
NATO-Beitritt von Bosnien und
Herzegowina das Schicksal der Ukraine
zur Folge hätte dann muss unsere Antwort
sein dass wir das Land umso mehr bei der
nato-anährung unterstützen und bei der
Umsetzung des membership Action plants
begleiten
ignorieren wir
ignorieren wir vor allem einen Fakt
nicht länger der Garant für
nachhaltestabilität in
Bosnien-Herzegowina ist und bleibt eine
realistische Perspektive zur
EU-Mitgliedschaft ihre Zukunft sind vor
allem die jungen Menschen in einem
vereinten Europa unterstützen wir die
Menschen vor Ort dass diese Zukunft für
ihr Land Realität werden kann vielen
Dank
der Appell von Thomas Hacker nach dieser
Debatte steht ja hier die namentliche
Abstimmung über diesen Bundeswehreinsatz
an die Linke hat schon angekündigt gegen
diesen Einsatz zu stimmen Jacqueline
nastic spricht jetzt für Ihre Fraktion
sie geehrte Frau Vorsitzender meine
Damen und Herren es wird schon ein angst
und bang wenn man bedenkt dass die
Ampelkoalition ausgerechnet auf dem
Wahlkampf wieder deutsche Soldaten
einsenden will nach mehr als 25 Jahren
gescheiterter
Bundeswehreinsätze schauen wir nach
Afghanistan nach Mali und gleich um die
Ecke ins Kosovo was ja wieder in ein
endlos-mandat beschlossen haben
ausgerechnet deutsche Soldaten sollen
für Frieden und Sicherheit in Bosnien
sorgen meine Damen und Herren es hatte
gute Gründe warum Deutschland vor zehn
Jahren aus diesem Mandat ausgestiegen
ist
und in einer Region auch noch wo vor 23
Jahren durch ein Völkerrechtsbruch eben
Krieg seitens Deutschlands und der NATO
geführt wurde scheint es jetzt wieder
nach einem Völkerrechtsbruch
auszuschauen wir alle wissen im Herbst
wird dieses Mandat euphor Altea vor dem
UN-Sicherheitsrat verlängert werden Herr
Kollege sie können sich ja gerne melden
aber sie brauchen nicht mal dazwischen
zu schreiben
wir alle wissen dass im Herbst euch vor
Altea vor dem UN-Sicherheitsrat
verlängert werden soll und das Russland
sehr wahrscheinlich sein Veto dagegen
einlegen wird
und wir beobachten ja auch dass sowohl
die US-Administration als auch das
Brüsseler Hauptquartier schon eine
NATO-Mission vorsorglich dafür
vorbereiten sie aber alle wissen dass
für eine NATO-Mission die nichts
völkerrechtsbrüchig ist sowohl
bosniakenkroaten als auch die besten
bosnischen Serben zustimmen sollen und
es sieht aber nicht danach aus als ob
die re:publica selbstgardin zustimmen
würde Mandate die das Völkerrecht
brechen lehnen wir linken ab
meine Damen und Herren Herr Ahmetovic
sie haben ja im bosnischen Fernsehen
ganz offen dazu aufgerufen der Hohe
Repräsentant möge dem Präsidenten der
re:publica siwska aus dem Amt werfen nun
ja wir linken mögen Herrn dodic nun
alles andere aber sollten Sie mal nicht
überdenken dass das genau Wasser auf die
Mühlen von solchen Nationalisten ist
dass sie von außen sich einmischen und
eben einen gewählten Präsidenten aus den
antjeden wohnen und wir linken sagen
dass es hoch gefährlich und das sollte
eben nicht vorkommen
von außen befeuerte Spannungen gerade
ethnische religiöse Zusammenhänge haben
noch nie für Frieden gesorgt meine Damen
und Herren einige haben es von ihnen ja
ganz offen hier gesagt um die Menschen
geht es ja gar nicht es geht um Russland
und China darum geht es ihnen doch wenn
ihnen wirklich die soziale Sicherheit
der Menschen in Bosnien wichtig gewesen
wäre dann hätten sie gerade
Entwicklungshilfe wirtschaftliche
Unterstützung aus dem datener Abkommen
die ganzen Jahre massiv unterstützt und
das ist nicht passiert sie verschweigen
ja auch den Einfluss Saudi-Arabiens und
der Türkei und dem wachsenden Islamismus
weil eben Bosnien mit all seinen
sozialen Problemen allein gelassen wurde
und das verurteilen wir auf Schärfste
an deutschen Soldaten wird eben die Welt
nicht friedlicher im Gegenteil und sie
riskieren damit ja auch sogar im Falle
eines Konflikts direkt Kriegspartei zu
werden das lehnen wir linken ab wir
lehnen dieses Mandat ab
[Applaus]
der Kollege ist angesprochen worden hat
den Wunsch nach einer Kurzintervention
und ich wünsche mir dass es eine kurze
Kurzintervention wird
ich möchte nicht noch länger diese
diesen Tagesordnungspunkt in der Länge
ziehen aber ich wurde direkt
angesprochen und möchte darauf kurz
eingehen Frau nastic
wir haben heute den 8 Juli
drei Tage vor dem 11 juli 11 juli 1995
Genozid ins trepenica und ich warte seit
Monaten seitdem ich direkt gewählt
worden mit dem Deutschen Bundestag sich
einmal von der Linkspartei höre dass sie
sich solidarisch den Opfern dass sie
sich solidarisch den Opfern von
streberini zu erklären ich warte seitdem
ich gewählt worden bin im Deutschen
Bundestag dass sie ein klarer Absage der
nationalistischen Politik für
müllersevic sagen und wenn wir mal zu
dodi kommen dodic ist derjenige den
Genozid von scrabenica leugnet und wir
würden sie mit dem denn umgehen der Hohe
Repräsentant hat die Fähigkeiten von der
Europäischen Union und von der
internationalen Gemeinschaft genau
solche Leute sich nicht an
internationales Recht halten und das
Internationale Strafgerichtshof von
Denner cut entschieden das ist ein
Genozid instabenica gibt und wenn das
geleugnet wird dann muss das klar
sanktioniert werden und Dodik war vor
einigen Tagen St Petersburg und hat von
freundschaftlichen Beziehungen Meeting
gesprochen wann distanzieren sie sich
auch mal davon das vermisse ich das
vermisse ich
mein Eindruck ist dass sie antworten
möchten bitteschön
also Herr achmedovic als erstes habe ich
an meiner Rede gesagt dass wir mit Herrn
Dodig und seinen Nationalismus ja nun
nichts zu tun haben möchten das habe ich
gesagt das haben Sie vielleicht überhört
so und jedes Kriegsverbrechen und
selbstverständlich die Insa sind
zutiefst zu verurteilen
so aber es revenita war jetzt eben nicht
der Tagesordnungspunkt sondern ein
auslandsmandat in das sie einsteigen und
sie müssen dann auch ehrlich sein dass
die Schaffung des Amtes des Hohen
Repräsentanten gar nicht erst
Bestandteil des datenabkommens gewesen
ist sondern im Nachhinein fast zwei
Jahre später geschaffen wurde und es hat
eben keine demokratische Legitimation
und sie fordern also dass ohne
demokratische Legitimation ein Präsident
dem wir wahrscheinlich alle hier
ablehnen für die AFD möchte ich gar
nicht sprechen aber trotzdem ist das
genau Wasser auf die Mühlen von ihm wenn
ein Präsident dann sagt ach guck mal von
Deutschland mischen Sie sich ein und
wollen sogar ein gewählten Präsidenten
absetzen finden Sie nicht dass das
widersprüchlich ist
so auf diese letzte Frage wird jetzt
keine Antwort geben weil bei einer
Kurzintervention immer nur eine Frage
eine Antwort erlaubt ist der Bundestag
diskutiert noch über den Einsatz der
Bundeswehr in Bosnien Herzegowina dann
werden die Abgeordneten hier namentlich
auch darüber abstimmen wir verlassen
jetzt das Plenum für ein paar Minuten
für einen kurzen Nachrichtenüberblick
aus dem Bonner Studio